joining me now to talk about that as
well as some of the Democrats
shenanigans on Capitol Hill this week is
counselor to the president Kellyanne
Conway Kellyanne thanks so much for
being here tonight first things first
what is the White House hearing about
Kim jong-un and has the president
reached out to anyone hi I will not
comment on that the president will make
any announcement about a head of state I
will just tell you that all of us
Jeannine will get our credible
information offline not online and
echoing what senator Graham just said
the offer that President Trump made to
North Korea really his entire presidency
stands that there can be great economic
liberation and the opportunity for the
people of North Korea and we be willing
to help with that but there would be
have to be so many conditions met first
not least of which is what the president
has been working toward for all three
years which is the verifiable complete
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
and the president is very firm on that
as he's tried to broker a deal in that
way he has he has placed sanctions they
have remained on North Korea and we've
been pretty tough on them as well but as
to the health condition of a foreign
leader I'm going to leave that to the
National Security Council for the
President himself to make any
announcements right okay I understand
that but it is highly unusual for him to
be as absent as he has been and I'm
going to ask you about something that's
just come out this evening in the Wall
Street Journal and that is that the
White House is planning on replacing a
Health and Human Services Secretary Alex
a czar that is more than just online
it's in The Wall Street Journal what say
you to that well what I would say to
that is secretary a czar has served for
over two years was in the Situation Room
yesterday at the task force briefing was
there I think most of the week and of
course is a big part of that he oversees
a huge budget over 60,000 employees and
the CDC the FDA Samsa and IH they're all
connected to if not reporting in some at
some level to the HHS secretary what I
find very curious and a bit
disappointing
every time I read a story about a
personnel change these days it has to do
with somebody who has oversight over the
pandemic and it's very unfortunate to me
that you have people some people wishing
or willing that dr. Falchi will be
silent or dr. Burks will quit or they'll
no longer be around or the Secretary of
HHS will be replaced in the middle of
this President handling a global
pandemic I mean that would think about
what you're wishing some people well you
know not be le gallienne you you make a
good point you make a good point and and
and I understand that where are you
coming from where you're going so let's
hit it on Joe Biden then okay now Joe
Biden apparently has come out and he
said that I think the exact quote is
something like he's not really happy
with the two trillion and he wants a
hell of a lot more that's quote than two
trillion dollars and he said that today
I mean is this all about printing more
money is he is the man focused delirious
is does he know what's going on he does
in this way he's trying to kowtow and
capitulate to the far left that has
overtaken the the Democratic Party the
irony Janine is that in saying this to a
wide-ranging interview to Politico today
Joe Biden sounds like many of the
far-left candidates he beat in the
primary and now he's trying to sound
like them even though he was able to
become the front-runner again after a
year of being the front-runner it was a
little secure witness but he's really
being he's giving in to the Craven
elements of his party for which there's
never enough money and what I found
really curious and regrettable about Joe
Biden's interview is that he was talking
about the things he'd want to invest in
and frankly they have nothing to do with
ridding us of the coronavirus and making
sure that we have vaccine therapeutics
that we can we can count on any hospital
surge or ventilator surge if in fact
there's another hot spot somewhere but
as we start to reopen pieces of the
economy state by state city by city when
it's appropriate and when the phases are
met that's what Joe Biden should be
focused on but it was you know he was
cursing in the interview of course he
had a head attacked
president but he really didn't offer any
solutions what he offered was the
typical grab bag of the green New Deal
there was a report a few short months
ago that that suggested households in
some of the key states would be up to
fifty seventy five thousand dollars per
cost per household if we overtime if we
actually put the green New Deal and
effect it may I remind everyone Janine
they were all counseling to AOC who I
think her power has really been
diminished Bernie Sanders is not the
nominee Nancy Pelosi doesn't pay much
attention or nobody followed her when
she voted against the latest the latest
economic package but when she she would
said we need the green adil I said
that's a great idea great idea they put
it to a vote in the Senate Cheney and
remember this one how many votes did he
get zero if you rounded out the next
nearest number that would be zero and
now you've got Joe Biden running on this
platform so it makes no sense President
Trump is making sure that our small
businesses are distressed industries are
needed and individuals in need are
getting that money through the cares Act
and we just got a new cash infusion one
hundred billion more for a seventy-five
billion more for hospitals 25 billion
more for research including vaccines and
then of course 300 billion plus more for
our small businesses that's what you
want to do with the money Heather the
government tied people again
Jillian very quickly and I've only got
30 seconds now you know this whole idea
of and the latest thing to come out on
Larry King where the mother of the
terror Reid the woman who's made the
allegation against Joe Biden is calling
in to Larry King complaining about her
daughter having a problem with a senator
I mean how do you think the Democrats
actually actually can get look at
themselves when they are so critical of
Republicans with no evidence and they've
got the guy running for president who's
being accused of sexual harassment if
not worse two things going on here
neither which is good for the Democratic
Party Janine the first is the obvious
the whole me to movement the people who
absolutely believed this person or that
person with very thinner and or no
evidence because of their political
leanings and because of whom they were
trying to stop from the Supreme Court or
from the presidency
so they they're not on solid ground here
they're being completely disingenuous
and hypocritical but not even giving
this woman her due
the second part is you have a lot of
Democrats tried to push Joe Biden out of
the race they didn't want him to be the
nominee now they're stuck with him and
they're using this as a backdoor excuse
to make me call into question can we
afford this kind yes that's right can we
afford this kind of a possible scandal
abra leading into the election and you
know Biden and hidin these last few
weeks has really helped him and when he
comes back out he's gonna have the
debate Donald Trump in answer questions
about Tara Reid and other people all
right Kellyanne Conway thanks for being
with us